okay so 1899 has a major ending that
sets up a lot of things for next time in
this video we're going to be breaking
down what happens and giving our
theories for what we think is going to
show up in season two I don't want to
waste your time as there's a lot to talk
about so spoiler alert anyway the season
ends with more breaking out of the
simulation that the voyage on the care
Bros has been she awakens to find
herself on the Prometheus which is of
course also the name of the abandoned
ship that they discovered in episode 1.
Captain Ike found a ship passengers list
on the Prometheus that had both their
names on it and this was one of the many
clues that they were in fact on the
vessel from the beginning now to me the
events in the series very much work as a
metaphor for what's going on in the real
world Maura was of course looking for a
brother who was in the Prometheus and
this extends to what we discover at the
end just in the same way that the
Kerberos was heading out to New York I
think in the passengers are heading out
to a new planet in order to start a new
life this is demonstrate in the text log
that we see at the end which says
survival Mission along with a list of
two coordinates clearly chronicling a
journey I think that both the events and
the Kerberos and what we learn may very
much parallel each other Maura is
looking for her missing brother and she
ends up discovering the truth about him
at the end showing she's at least
completed this Mission now I think that
the thing the passengers are doing on
the Kerberos are also what they're doing
in real life for example Lucian will be
traveling to this new planet to get
life-saving surgery that will stop him
from having seizures ramir and Angel
could be escaping persecution for their
sexuality and so on and so forth because
of this I also think it hints out what's
going on with Elliot in the series we
discover that Mora's father built an
asylum to study her mother who is
suffering from a decline in her
cognitive abilities he wanted to
understand the human brain more and it
is possible that Elliot gained the same
condition Mora very much mirrored her
father and along with her husband Daniel
she could be seen keeping Elliot in a
simulation now my guess is that it will
be revealed in season two that is either
dead or at least at death's door the
simulation could have the ability to
alter one's perception of time and just
in the same way that one can live out
days in a dream it is possible that time
works differently in a Sim as well she
may potentially be prolonging the time
that she has with Elliot through keeping
him imprisoned in a simulation that she
can visit and loop this is of course
similar to the beetle Alfred that Elliot
found Maura told him it was cruel to
keep it in a cage this is clearly a
lesson that she's ignored for herself
even Daniel thinks that the child should
be set free and instead of being allowed
to exist in the real world he's forced
to remain in his prison because Mora
can't let go during the many death
scenes on the ship towards the end
Maura's father talks about how people
refuse to let go of the attachments they
have and this is very much echoed in her
now I'm still unsure of what the Elia is
dead or not and potentially Morris
taking him to this new destination in
order to try and find a cure this would
be similar to what's happening with
Lucian and who knows Lucian might even
be Elliot he stuck with a woman he
doesn't want to be with and has been
forced to live a certain way big big
reach there yeah but it's just something
I noticed with the similarities now
Elliot being dead is of course
represented by the fact that his rumors
beneath a child's gray that exists at
Maura's home what about the way he acts
in the simulation makes it seem like
he's a real person and Mora's father
even reveals a lot of things to him he
would be someone who would know the
child was really dead or not so doing
this would be a waste of time for him if
he in fact was the child's room being in
the grave could maybe be a metaphor of
how he's got one foot in the grave and
the access back and forth May symbolize
that he's at that store rather than
being there I think the series will very
much be about moral learning to let go
and this has of course been echoed
throughout several of the characters now
as for what's going on with her brother
we actually have a lot of clues for this
already in the series we learn that
their father is the owner of the company
that refurbished the Prometheus and also
the Kerberos I think this is very much
the case in real life with him also
owning the company that the premier
atheist belongs to anyway Kieran likely
launched a coup to Take Over Control of
this and he trapped both his sister and
father in a simulation in order to
launch his plan say Mora was taking
Elliot to get cured this would give him
an opportunity to launch his plan to
trap her in his Sim there's obviously a
lot of similarities to Inception and
just in the same way that the group
launched their mind Invasion on a plane
Kieran could have done this on this
spaceship as well Maura transporting his
son would be when she's at the most
vulnerable it's something he could plan
ahead for and I think it would be a big
way to handle kieran's Arc now I think
it'll be revealed that because of their
father's experiments on their mother
that this had a massive effect on his
personality Maura didn't mind trapping
her own son so there is the potential
akiran has a similar outlook on life
he's likely carrying out experiments on
the passengers whilst keeping them
trapped in these loops and running
through his own tests that push the
brink of their sanity their father
carried out experiment to try and
understand the human brain and he may be
doing a similar thing through the use of
similar relations now it seems like his
plan might even involve Maura as he
leaves the joking out behind and even
reaches out to her I think you will want
to make her more of an ally in his coup
to take control from their abusive
father and that he'll sear as someone
who should join him rather than being
against him this would explain why
Maura's father wants to go without his
daughter as he might be aware that
they're working together on the outside
it seemed like he was fully against her
and him escaping without her cutting at
the fact that the Peril Partners however
he's clearly a bad dude due to what he's
putting the other passengers through
we've also gone back and forth over
what's happening with Daniel and I still
don't know if he's a real person or not
he does inform more that her brother has
taken over the ship so he at least is
aware of what's going on in the real
world however he says he'll be there
when she wakes up and this isn't the
case therefore it's possible it'll be
revealed he's an AI within the
simulation that's programmed to break
more out if her brother takes over he's
basically Neo in The Matrix and can
alter things and shift them his entire
my mission is to help Maura Escape so a
thing there is potential there that he's
just a program running through a fails
safe to get Mora out but there is the
possibility that he's in the real world
which I think would make a lot of sense
from a writer's point of view obviously
Maura's gonna need someone in season two
that basically gives her an exposition
dump at the start and guides her through
what's really going on so Daniel could
very much fit that character and yeah it
does make sense to include him in the
future in some way now from a writer's
point of view the idea of simulations
also opens up a lot of possibilities for
next time because of this we could
explore so many different times in both
the past and present other places I'd
love to see are a Westworld type Wild
West Medieval Times which you know these
dark guys could nail modern day the 80s
70s for those flares had no swinging 60s
yeah baby now there's also other cabins
on the Prometheus with each one
potentially carrying their own worlds
and rules we have the crew of the ship
to me as well who aren't part of this
system what I love about the feature of
the show is that we have so many
different directions they can take
things and obviously when simulations
are involved you always have the
possibility that this entire ending is
the Sim itself Maura might not even be
in space and yet just something to think
about when you look at those final few
scenes
who knows but it's clear that we aren't
in with the twists and turns yet and Doc
was famous for constantly pulling the
rug out from under your feet I can even
see this point where Morris revealed as
being someone who willingly entered the
simulation rather than being trapped
there she clearly wanted to keep Elliot
there so it makes sense that she
deliberately wanted to remain there too
Daniel's key memory was at a point where
she and more ahead had a child whereas
Maura's memory was back at her childhood
home this is likely why she didn't
remember having a child and she also
made her 1899 Avatar have the backstory
that she couldn't have children whatever
she was doing she was clearly doing it
so that she could hide the truth about
Elliot from herself whereas Daniel was
desperate to break her out of it I think
it's gonna be revealed that she didn't
really want to leave perhaps she
willingly gave up control of the ship to
her brother so that she could go and
live in the simulation there's been
thought experimental years that have
discussed whether someone would rather
live in a simulation where their life is
perfect or face her up to the cold
harshness of reality the mature majority
of people said they'd rather remain in
the real world with all its flaws but
there is still a minority that want to
be in a Sim Maura could be one of those
people and I think it's going to be
revealed that she went into the Sim
voluntarily so that she could be with
her son either way we definitely have
some more twists on the way and I'd of
course love to hear your thoughts on
what we're getting I love that everyone
is basically stuck on the ship and that
they're gonna have to find a way to get
along when the truth comes out lots of
things to look forward to and hopefully
we get an announcement of that season
two sooner rather than later now we are
in a competition right now giving away
three copies of House of the Dragon
season one on the 15th of December all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts and
theories it's one big Theory time
for you and yeah make sure you drop them
below now if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the ending which will be
linked on the screen right now we talk
about the whole series all the little
hidden details in it the basic plots and
influences that led towards his show and
I'm really proud of the video so
definitely go head over there right
after this without the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
Paul I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]